first of all let me start by saying
congrats you didn't crash the ferrari
so let's go let's go with that um
congratulations
uh but i am curious so what do you think
people would be surprised to learn about
the making of the tomorrow war
that they're not going to read and press
notes or you know what i mean like
what's
something that they might not know yeah
i mean
uh uh something they might not know um
well let's here uh something uh
you know for i i betty gilpin uh i cast
betty gilpin in this movie to play chris
pratt's
wife uh she had a really amazing
audition and the scene that she
auditioned
uh with is a scene that's not in the
movie um
and it's my my biggest regret as a
director is
that i wasn't able to uh uh keep this
scene
uh she it's a story it was it was a
scene about about the backstory of chris
and betty's uh uh
chris betty's relationship um and uh
betty was every single take
uh and betty was doing different things
and inventing different things
um all the time in each take but every
single take brought you to tears
uh she was it was really it was a window
into their relationship
uh that uh you know i really
uh yeah it's something i really was
really fond of
and that i wish that you know like again
my biggest regret as a filmmaker on this
movie is
i wasn't able to find a way to make that
work in the film uh but that's something
maybe that's not the the anecdote you
were you were looking for but that was
uh that was something that i think about
a lot uh in terms of this movie that i
that uh yeah betty betty is an amazing
actor and
i'm hoping that if we make a sequel we
get more betty in the movie
well i wanted to ask you when it comes
to like this is coming out on amazon
it's going to be streaming
how does it work i've always wondered
you would think that
the ability to put deleted scenes or an
extended
cut even if it's rough online for
streaming would be
easier but yet nobody does it yeah it's
weird i mean you know obviously
on itunes they have some of that stuff
if you in the itunes extras
and things like that when you buy
something but yeah i i
you know i hope that that stuff is still
kind of in the you know like
you know there's still a comment you
know is there going to be a commentary
track is there going to be other
things like that that those are the
things that i love i mean i'm i collect
you know blu-rays and dvds and things
like that like you know i've got a
literally you there's a there's a door
in my apartment that's just like
you open that door and it's just a wall
of it's just a wall of movies
so um and that's not all of them but uh
uh
you know i i'm hoping that that we will
get a chance to do stuff like that
because there's lots of there's a couple
of
scenes that are funny and just couldn't
make it into the movie but there's but
there are
great little you know just little
moments in the film so i'm and and
and the scene with betty and then oh
yeah you know commentary and all the
stuff that you normally do and
things like that you know uh yeah i i
hope that we still get to do that so
hopefully that's coming i'm curious
let's let's jump into the time travel in
the movie
you you you say what the time travel is
but then you don't
like spend a lot of time sort of going
into the minutia of it was that a
conscious choice
yeah yeah i mean i wanted you to
experience this you know
chris pratt's in every single scene this
movie is is somewhat of a character
study of
chris pratt's character so to you watch
you see everything from chris pratt's
point of view so it's like signs
uh you know versus uh versus
independence day independence day is a
movie that
you can cut to the pentagon you can cut
to the white house you can cut to you
know people around the world
experiencing an alien invasion besides
the movie
where you experience an alien invasion
from a farmhouse and you can only see
what the
people in the farmhouse see and that's
that's it our movie is like that where
i'm not cutting to all these things i'm
only seeing what chris pratt see so i'm
seeing stuff
either through the media that chris
pratt absorbs or through chris pratt's
direct experience with things so he's
getting
he goes to a briefing on time travel he
gets a little bit of some briefing about
the way time travel works but then he's
off
you know and then you know the alarm
goes off and then they all have to
they'll have to you know you know get to
stations and and get sent to the future
so i kind of wanted and since the time
since
really since the movie also isn't one of
those movies where
the time travel mechanics are used in
the solving of the problem of the movie
i also felt like we don't need to
necessarily explain
because it doesn't directly affect the
things that chris pratt is going to do
we don't necessarily need to explain
that plus i think there are some things
because we've all experienced time
travel movies there's assumptions that
an audience can make about some
things later on in the movie uh as far
as like
what maybe yvonne and chris are talking
about that i think are
um that are stuff that we because we are
smart audience members and we know
a lot about the time travel tropes and
stuff like that we can
yeah we can make some assumptions and
and i feel i feel like that was
you know omitting so that was okay yeah
because i was wondering
because listen with time travel there's
a lot of way you know a lot of
you know different uh uh futures if you
will like and because you can have that
speech of don't touch that or don't
you kill someone in the past it affects
you can really get into the minutia of
it
so you know you know what i mean yeah
yeah
absolutely yeah and so i so from me i
chose to just
i chose to give you what chris pratt
chris pratt's version
of what he experienced in time travel
which was
a brief thing about this and then
suddenly he's getting thrown into the
future it's like
we're gonna you know it's like we're in
the infancy of of flight
and we're gonna have to take a
transatlantic flight even though we're
still in wright brothers
day so you're gonna get in and now
you're gonna go and we can't explain you
all the
principles of flight you're just going
to get in this you're going to get in
this plane and we're going to take off
we're going to see how far we can get
you probably know this about me i always
like asking about how long a first cut
was or a rough cut i'm always fascinated
by the editing process
so how long was your like original
director's cut the director's cut
probably i guess what i would
because the process was because of covet
and a few other things the process was
a little more a little less formal than
other
you know if this had been in another
time but i would say that like let's say
that the
the the long version of a movie that
where it sort of felt a little bit like
the movie
uh was was you know closer to three
hours than not
um you know like that it was definitely
a long
and then it was just a struggle to go
okay how much of this how much of this
can we lose
um and some that's a financial thing
because there was like bigger there's
some bigger stuff for the action
scenes and some other stuff that just
you know from a financial standpoint we
had to make some tough decisions
um but but some of it also was just like
okay let's this movie needs to be moving
at this point we can't belabor
some of these things and stuff that you
didn't you know the audience really
wouldn't need you know it's not
something
anybody would ever miss you know there's
some jokes and things like that i mean
they always sort of
hate to cut you know somebody being
really funny or doing something really
really great but
i think for the most part other than the
scene with betty we made really good
choices
when did you decide to have sam set the
all-time movie record for saying the
word [ __ ]
that was in script that wasn't that was
in the script phase when we
you know zach wrote a script that didn't
have a lot of humor
in it and so one of my jobs was because
i knew there was gonna be stuff that was
very serious and sort of self
could could could go over into being
self serious in a way that's not
appealing
so i wanted there'd always be some
levity to the movie um
and so i you know and and when i even
when i was pitching the movie i pitched
sam as uh as as
charlie like even before i got the job i
said you gotta hire this guy's charlie
he's he's gonna
provide a lot of fun to this movie and
every man quality
that kind of thing and you should hire
other comedians i mean you know marilyn
and
mike mitchell and people like that were
not far out of my mind for for
just filling out the army of the
ordinary
um so when uh when we were kind of
adding levity to the film
uh one of the thoughts i had was you
know when [ __ ] goes down the very first
time i wanted
i wanted sam to just yeah i think i
think in the script it said
uh [ __ ] times one thousand uh
and that that was that was that was in
it is in his dialogue line and that's
and then sam i kid you not literally
went down
four stories uh running and firing and
saying [ __ ] so he
we and we had this descender rig that
just followed him all the way down you
know
the the whole all four stories of sam
just running down the stairs
firing reloading firing firing [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
that that take that see that should also
just that
take should be on uh on some sort of
extras
uh thing that you can that you can watch
after you watch the movie
yeah i'm gonna say you should just give
that to collider as a collider exclusive
and we'll write
you know just throwing that out there um
one of the things about this movie is
and i couldn't believe it is
you did a bad voice too i thought the
movie was coming to a close
but that was just the end of the second
chapter um so talk about the fact that
like there's a it's a surprising
narrative structure if you will
yeah yeah yeah it's almost like a forex
kind of thing right in a way
um yeah i mean uh you know there's
distinct chapters to this movie you know
there's the opening chapter you've got
the people coming out of the sky
at the world cup and and landing on the
field and and you know
before that you've got a little bit of
like just a little feeling of what's
going on with this family and and
there's some
stuff that maybe when the movie later
you can read between the lines but it's
like
you get a sense of a little bit of this
family that people come out of the sky
and then you kind of get into a little
the children of men dystopian thing
and then the movie goes into now and
then also the sci-fi premises start
coming
with getting arm-banded going to going
to the future
stuff like that um you feel like you're
in a war movie for a second and you're
in a horror movie you know there's
there's elements of you know the
stairwell scene is like a hitchcock you
know brian de palma
scene you know and then from my from my
standpoint or what i want to do with
suspense and that kind of thing
um and then you uh and then and then you
go into the the stuff of the helicopters
and the nest
and and the deep swell and defending the
deep swelling it's got sort of almost
like a western
old western kind of thing and and you're
you're getting into
you know chris pratt's you know some of
the chris pat's backstory and all that
stuff
and for me i wanted the next thing you
know i wanted you
to i wanted that feeling that you had
where it's like oh my god is this movie
going to end what's what's happening
here
and then all of a sudden oh [ __ ] there's
another thing
and all those people that we met earlier
in the movie all
of a sudden oh those people are all
going to pay off now here i'm going to
are you going to meet i'm going to show
you all those people in the beginning
the movie and now they're all going to
pay off and one of the things in the
test
screenings that was was really great and
really satisfying
is that the audience when they watched a
test screening
they started laughing like when when sam
showed up and then they start talking
about the volcano kid and they start
laughing
about the volcano kid and then he and
then you know the
he shows up and then they go to the the
dodd in the in the in the um you know
at the air base and then when they say
you know you need a pilot and people are
laughing before they cut
to jk because they're they know the
movie is now
the movie you showed you these people
you didn't know how they were going to
come back later because
you didn't know how they're going to use
then all sudden every single one of them
comes back
and there's just a sense of joy to that
kind of thing that the audience you know
that gives the audience a sense of like
oh we're we're just
you know the movies the movie is is is
is uh
is playing a little bit of a trick on us
by introducing those people and making
them go away and now making them come
back
in in a meaningful way so uh that was
fun to sort of like experience kind of
like a rolling laugh
like that uh it was great uh i
definitely have to switch to something
else just because i'm a you know as you
know uh kind of a fan of this lego
batman
[Music]
and movie know just kind of um so i am
curious where are you at
in the production of that um and what
can you tease about it
well right now right now there's uh
because
lego is uh left warner brothers and is
now
working universal there probably won't
be a lego batman
sequel unfortunately i am i'm sorry
to uh to say that but i don't think
they're gonna be making a lego batman
i am devastated yes that sucks
yeah i know we had a lot of you know
well you know we had dan harmon and his
team
working on a script for the lego batman
sequel that was sort of a
uh it had a boogie nights-esque
structure
where you're sort of simultaneously
telling the story of the justice league
and then
in the present time as well as and and
batman and
his relationship uh with the justice
league as well as telling the story of
the justice league of how they came
together
and uh uh it was
it was something that was gonna be
really special it was really uh they did
they did a really good job it's gonna be
really funny um
uh but yeah i hope you know maybe
someday that'll
resurrect that in another way but uh
yeah but right now that uh
the universal has uh universal work with
lego and uh
uh they're gonna i mean obviously
they're gonna do something really cool
with the movies hopefully
uh uh but uh but yeah um
but yeah there won't be like a batman uh
feel like i just got punched in the face
let's switch to something else that is
something that is positive um
so i heard johnny quest is moving along
nicely and that perhaps you have a
recent script that people are happy with
yeah uh what can you say about johnny
quest and is that your next project
the next project is probably going to be
uh renfield that's that's the next
project i'm working on which is the
story of dracula's assistant
so it's so it's a story uh it's it's
it's a
it's a it's a movie about codependency
at the end of the day that's that's
that's it's a it's a
uh it's about what we do uh for other
people
um what we're willing to what we're
willing to do for other people
and how to uh uh when you when you sort
of
throw yourself into a relationship with
someone
to the detriment of yourself how you can
get out of that kind of thing
but it's a it's a it's a horror movie
it's an action movie and it's a comedy
uh do you think you're filming that this
year
i yeah i hope so yeah i hope by the end
of the year yeah absolutely
so but for as a fan of johnny quest what
can you say i know you're developing
that
what can you say about that project and
the version of it that excites you
um johnny quest is uh uh
you know what i like about johnny quest
is it's kind of about the family that
you make
you know we have all of all of your
favorite johnny quest characters and
then some
deep some deep dives and that kind of
thing but it is about
how the people you know when
johnny is a character who experienced
grief
his mother his mother died and it's
about how
um the people around you
can help you overcome grief that's at
the end of the day there's
there's something about that but it's
also very uh uh
it's raider's lost ark um it's it's a
world hopping movie uh trying to solve a
real world
uh looking for a real world uh
uh artifact to stop uh
a big global catastrophe um
and it's really i really love the
characters i really love the
relationships
in johnny quest uh the writers uh
matt and craig did an amazing job and um
yeah i'm hoping that um
i'm hoping warner bros wants to make
that movie really soon because it's
gonna be a really cool
uh it's gonna be a really cool it's
gonna be a big movie like tomorrow it's
gonna be a big
in scope uh family action movie
uh i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
uh thank you for your time
and uh you know i'm sure i'll talk to
you soon yes
yes